one hey guys this day of your court
orders well the animation [ __ ] in a
video what's up hey guys
Joe token is all discord or I'm gonna
start one word one word one word one
word go back ago okay hey hey guys hey
guys go watch the anime fidgets spinner
video on corridor P this is how you edit
with editing a video so I'll just show
you the current version of it that it is
this exams so right now I'm about to do
my own version of stamina goes at it
knee go to the past standard a pass now
I'm gonna do a pass and then we're all
going to see what works best
so dumb so I like how like the opening
tighter and faster the beat of me going
the flashback is totally working
people are always noticed what happened
they understood the pigeons better stop
and they start laughing I went to a
distraction mode okay that was good I
feel like we still need to sell it a
little bit more though because I think
what's really gonna sell it is like the
sound of the biz spinners flowing down
been like like no I figure it's like
like helicopter blades well that's
really good idea yeah yeah yeah that's
really good so I got it run fortunately
but cool man all right well I will do
this I'll see you around 7:00 all right
sounds good
condition of the back yeah but now we're
just kind of doing some polish stuff oh
yeah when you're watching this anime
fidget spinners is done and uploaded to
the corridor channel what are you doing
go check it out
pause this video right now go watch the
fidget spinner video and then come back
and watch this clunk
watch both videos as long as you watch
it Peter made a dragon
here hey sorry Greg dragons man okay so
we got two dragon shots in this video
I'm going to talk about the second one
because a lot cooler here's the raw shot
by itself of D doing a thing so the
first thing I did was I went through an
emotion track to the shot so that all
the objects would follow the camera
second thing I did was I found the
dragon 3d models I got the dragon
modeled off TF 3d am calm and here you
can see them in all their non energy
glory they're not very high quality but
they work for the video and they came
texture they did come textured is very
nice I actually have no idea what
they're from if it's a game or what but
I'm glad they exist so basically what
Ren wanted for the shot if you want to
be dragons to swirl around the camera
which is kind of complicated to animate
you know usually when you're animating
something you'll give it a skeleton and
have each bone move individually and
you'll just animate it that way but what
I thought would be more efficient for
this is to actually animate the Dragons
along a curve here are my two curves
here that the dragons are supposed to
follow and you can see through the
camera this is roughly the path that
they go on basically you just say you
grab a line and you distort the line and
however you want the path to go and then
I just tell the dragon to snap to that
path on the top dragon you know I made
him spin around because I thought it was
a little bland and needed a little
personality so I had them rotated who
that Susan about what McAuliffe what are
you I'm all sweaty sorry yeah all day
right but just slapping a sponge
seriously for unions oh my no phone I
know dude I got this pixel phone and
it's awesome but I can't do hi message
and I've got this limit for route text
so I can't see Orson of texting with
somebody's design to drive anymore what
okay
hi it's big holiday yeah I know it's
incredible in every other way like every
time you get a phone number it
automatically searches for who it is
so you see who's calling uh-huh a fancy
color ID base be kind of nice
yeah if there's lots of great things and
faster than iPhone but that's crazy
though let me see it what else is cool
about it I know it's got like some cool
it's also got the - connection - but
it's just like really nice that's how
are you liking a switching from Apple to
you literally plug one phone and to the
other with a cord and then it transfers
all your contacts and photos and half
since we think yeah so it's like I don't
even know work how do you like the UI
way clean and faster look I'm like I'll
open my email and I'm like I want to
open and read it or Google Drive and
it's like instant Wow everything
everything just like instantaneous
basically all I build another week to
return it I'm holding off and so you can
see how long I can last but okay I know
and then what I did next because you can
see in this shot there's lighting on the
ground because dragons are like energy
beings or whatever to do that I
recreated the alleyway in blender using
this basically just three planes making
three-quarters of a box and roughly made
the shape of the hallway lined it up
with the camera so that just goes right
along and see that they're lighting up
the ground what I did next was I brought
the Dragons into After Effects and then
to get them all glowing all crazy and
stuff five first find edges and then
inverse tint oh God thanks bro
was it just a prank red was it just a
prank no I didn't think so
then I throw on some levels as peruse
and then videocopilot color vibrance
which is one of my favorite plugins
which just interprets colors in really
pretty ways it's basically like tint but
it looks a lot better
made the Dragons all red then real smart
motion blur which calculated the correct
motion blur you know how blur they
should be flying at the camera and
everything then I layered all that
together added a bunch more glow added
kind of a ghosting effect to it you know
make it look more energy like and there
you go there's the final text and we're
just going to wait for it to render out
the whole
all right so it's the last day before
anime fidgets Pinter comes out every was
working real hard getting it done Gabe
just gave me a couple really cool
thumbnail options one bin is really
funny because the right amount of edge
what am i goo well I like these intense
face is actually kind of sad like
there's a big scene some [ __ ] break or
something hmm
and Carmichael's working on the sound
design right now what's up for you gonna
just inflate everyone talking yeah yeah
it was so [ __ ] loud try great though
music deceptive quick to computer and
Mike has just come in to kind of sit
down with me and put the last finishing
touches on the video so my job before
the video goes live tomorrow is to make
sure there's logos in the beginning
there's stuff to click on at the end
like say a sizzle reel for the San Luca
channel Oh be I'll be like hey Mike
what's going on
oh hey Nico what's up and what are you
doing here at corridor digital well I
just should have here at corridor
digital to work on this anime business
better vision amazing you guys that's
great yes we work together on this video
it's a collaboration between Mike Deva
and you can check out my channel at
youtube.com
sucker so obviously this is like four so
I have a question yeah hit me what's the
coolest video for people to go watch
right now right now yeah the coolest
video on internet right now let's
animate agent spinner you can go to
youtube.com slash corridor I click on
the link below the very first link in
the description or the link at the end
of this video go watch that video it's
really good you guys should check it out
look I'm color grading it right now
actually no it's already uploaded
Oh